You know maybe we went too hardcore on
these guys. Yeah why do you think we never go
back to a place we've already been you
know how many adventures we could get
out of p*rge planet Morty gear world
I don't sequel it's called integrity
here put this back on your face.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this is going to be my Rick and
Morty season 4 episode 7 video there
were a ton of Easter eggs and references
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos will do
a Rick and Morty merch giveaway all you
have to do to enter is just be a
subscriber and leave your favorite joke
from the episode on the video careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet will do top 10 and
Easter eggs as we go along starting with
number 10 the title of the episode
primordius obviously a reference to
prometheus the prequel to the alien
movies as is the case a lot of times the
title of the episode is mostly just
connected to the overall bit that
they're doing in the genre for the
episode like Rick and Morty but make it
aliens a couple years ago they even did
a Rick and Morty season 3 trailer that
was an official alien covenant movie
crossover promo with a much more
accurate looking version of the builders
spaceship in this episode they open on a
very lv-426 looking asteroid type planet
with a shot of a crashed alien ship it's
different from the crashed alien ship in
the first Alien movie but everyone gets
the reference that they're going for and
the other big thing that they do with
the episode is tell it in a very
nonlinear way like The Hangover the
episode actually starts around the
middle of the story when they're just
escaping the facehuggers figuring out
why they've been on this planet for so
long number 9 the other big twist of the
episode is the writer revealed is meant
to be a Rick and Morty adventure but
what if Rick and Morty are the villains
of the episode instead of the
traditional villains that you would
think of as the face huggers like within
the Alien franchise face hookers are
terrible they lay eggs in you that grown
to chest bursting xenomorph skilling you
when they're born but because it's Rick
and Morty they have a couple callbacks
to the unity episode with Rick and Morty
essentially messing up their society
even though they're facehuggers they're
parasitic they seem kind of bad we
learned later during the summer montage
that they have a relatively positive
Society that Rick and Morty just
completely ripped through and destroy
there have been a lot of episodes in the
past that have portrayed Rick and Morty
as the assholes of the episodes like
Morty inadvertently Cronenberg in his
entire original earth causing them to
have to pack up and head to another one
we learn about Morty's browsing
preferences and his extensive knowledge
of website algorithms and his
apparent desire to share his love of
them with Jessica when he goes on and on
about hoping that Jessica is as much of
a degenerate as he is with some of the
same kinks we learned that Rick really
loves M&Ms you notice that most of the
bodies of these people are either the
pink aliens from world leaderly
conspiracy in season 3 or these blue
aliens there are a couple others that
show up from different races through the
episode because these are parasites
they're facehuggers so they just take
whatever they can get anybody that crash
lands on their asteroid number 8 we
don't find out till later in the episode
but as they start to mess with they're
now dead facehuggers we find out that
they were actually in a relationship
because the way they tell the episode in
a nonlinear way we don't really learned
what happened to them till we get to the
summer part of the episode where she
tells the backstory and as gross as that
part of the episode was with them
getting together summer is telling that
backstory Ricky yells at her for making
a bunch of stuff up like that didn't
actually happen I think that's the
writers way of giving themselves an out
like Rick and Morty didn't actually kiss
in the episode even though there was
another kissing reference in last week's
episode like Rick and Morty didn't
actually do that because technically it
was their facehuggers doing it and
summer was probably lying about them
doing it anyway so it probably never
happened they set up the bit about the
host bodies laying eggs and dying every
half an hour the joke there is that a
half an hour is the length of a typical
Rick and Morty episode with commercials
they pay that joke off at the end of the
episode when Rick and Morty after about
a half an hour of the episode feel like
they're going to lay an egg and die but
turns out they just really had to take a
deuce in the middle of the living room
while watching interdimensional cable
number 7 speaking of which this is their
second interdimensional cable joke in
two consecutive episodes there was a
huge Rick rant in the episode about why
they don't revisit old bits and episodes
when he breaks the fourth wall again
like he says they could do a ton more
stories on the purge world or gear world
but people would hate it and by people
they're referring to the fans so it's
more meta commentary from Dan and Justin
talking to the fandom explaining why
they're not going to keep doing the same
episodes every single season and because
of that speech in the two consecutive
interdimensional cable jokes it kind of
makes me feel that unless they're
totally faking us out they're not going
to do another
proper interdimensional cable three
episode this season but just because
they claim that they're not going to be
recycling old episodes doesn't mean
they're never going to follow up on evil
Morty or any of the other major
overarching stories it just means that
they're not going to rush to do another
episode set on the Citadel of Rick's
exactly like they did during season 3 so
when they do go back to those
overarching story characters and
elements they'll just be done in totally
different ways Rick makes a sick burn
about film school kids and crappy
student films I'm sure you'll turn this
into a beautiful short film that your
parents will have to pay for Morty
that's mostly the writers making fun of
themselves because most of them went to
film school and had to make student
films that their parents probably had to
pay for they start to piece together
their backstory a little bit but it's
not clear how many days they've been on
this planet because it's been long
enough for them to create a magazine for
their new society that summer help them
create in profile Morty for it for big
cover story Rick uses that to make a
sick burn on print media he's not wrong
when he says getting into print media
right now is a terrible idea in real
life most newspapers and traditional
magazines are starting to go out of
business number 6 we find out that
facehugger Rick is a YouTube celebrity
in their society but it's not Rick
Sanchez it's his face hugger that's the
YouTube celebrity spitting out all these
truths about host bodies and eggs and
their way of life I also love that he
asks for likes please like and subscribe
Morty reminds us that he's watched so
many web videos that he's become
an expert in cheap apartments
architecture and design that's a whole
lot of videos the special
spaceship that they're trying to
construct a fire eggs to Earth totally
looks like a d*ng if you look in the
background up enough Rick and Morty
episodes they add phallic shapes like
this all the time like some of these
rocket ships at the end of season 3
episode 1 and now you can't unsee it
Morty loses his sh*t again when all the
other aliens get pissed at him for
making them do a bunch of work for
nothing because he tries to call it off
which is a nice callback to the purge
episode where he just completely loses
it on that guy trying to write that
fanfiction Rick then goes on to directly
mention the purge episode when he goes
on his rant later in the episode we get
another celebrity cameo this is alan
tudyk he's the alien that's asking why
they're face huggers haven't blinked in
a long time before they take off running
the number 5 Rick and Morty made their
big Star Wars reference like who cares
about a ton of semi faceless
stormtroopers dying and that's when the
writers really turned them into the
villains of the episode as they said
like brick and Morty are the evil people
the facehuggers are supposed to be the
good people during the episode we learn
about a bunch more hidden weapons on
Rick's spaceship it has a gun turret
just like the Millennium Falcon another
Star Wars reference Rick and Morty try
to banter just like Luke Skywalker and
Han Solo during a new hope while Morty's
blasting as many things as possible they
reference the Twin Towers then break the
fourth wall again when they call it
cheap low-hanging fruit as if the
writers wanted to make them the villains
of the episode but didn't want to make
them so irredeemable that fans in real
life would get really upset about the
references they were making but for some
reason decide that facehugger Pearl
Harbor isn't too edgy for them I guess
you can blame all these replicas of
Earth locations on summer because the
facehuggers were getting their
inspiration for this society in their
plans from her they do another Star Wars
joke about skip jumping when Rick uses
the technique to create a giant blast
radius blowing up a giant group of
aliens and some buildings surrounding
them before going home completely
forgetting the summer had been with them
the whole time Rick makes another
political saudi-arabia
terrorism reference when Beth is
questioning the logic of their real
world tragedy references they set up the
Jerry beekeeping bit with his honey
Jerry zone is a reference to Newman's
Own the actor Paul Newman in real life
has a brand of food products they donate
their profits to charity Jerry is
apparently just doing it for the honey
it seems they wind up paying that bit
off at the end of the episode when
summer's friend Tricia who showed up a
bunch in the past couple of seasons says
she wants to bang him because apparently
the beekeeping turns her on that's more
of a side bit about the lamest person in
the episode somehow coming off is the
most interesting person because the
family was so bored with him at the
table that they completely ignored him
when he was talking about it number four
Rick has his big rant about them not
redoing episodes going back to places
that they've been while they're going
back to a place they've just been sort
of illustrating the point hammering at
home to go get summer Rick is also
breaking the fourth wall again while
he's doing this when they land the
spaceship and opened the doors beer
bottles spill out both sides the exact
same way they did in the pilot
so just more references to them redoing
old bits and episodes they do their big
ronin warriors anime suit up montage
it's been a long time since I've watched
that series but that's what these suits
in the swords are references to Rick
apparently also has adult ADHD because
he's been taking adderall either too
much or too little he's not sure we find
out he has another secret drill weapon
in his ship burrowing a path through the
ground to the place where Summers been
this whole time and they revealed that
she's been the glorious Empress since
the beginning of the episode when they
get locked up the song that Morty sings
nobody knows is actually an old African
American slavery song that goes back a
long long time but wasn't actually
recorded for the first time until 1867
but it's shown up all over pop culture
movies it's been re-recorded a billion
times so even if you don't know exactly
where the song came from you've probably
heard it at some point in a movie or a
TV show somewhere they used the song to
set up the bit about the musical notes
forcing aliens to lay eggs prematurely
which they then pay off by the end of
the episode number three summer goes on
our big back story rant she apparently
really likes podcasts and they get
really met again with more tea and
summer referencing their core character
traits as characters in a TV show like
Morty really likes to play with himself
I own it it's authentic to my character
the joke was summer in the toothpick is
that she's desperate to have a thing
because she's typically a background
character and she doesn't appear in all
the episodes so she just wants to seem
like a much bigger character they try to
turn it into a bigger joke with the
failed facehugger implantation later as
part of the reason why she was able to
win them over and become their empress
but Rick's burn about podcasting being
boring sounds kind of like Dan Harmon in
the writers making fun of harmontown
because Dan Harmon just ended harmontown
after several years of weekly podcast
episodes because it sounds like as Rick
says he got bored of it this facehugger
that's been alive for seven minutes is
played by Nolan North he's actually been
in multiple episodes so far this season
Dan Harmon sings the theme song to the
glorious while they're building this new
society that summers helping them create
which Rick and Morty later destroy in
the episode when they go on their tear
the Rick gloor xot starts his YouTube
channel they do a bit about office
politics with the glorious when summer
tries to get Morty back by firing his
face
and replacing with another team member
setting off the part of the episode that
we saw at the beginning they do that
really gross bit about the Rick
facehugger getting with the morty
facehugger which probably didn't happen
according to the logic of the episode
when they get recaptured we learned this
summer is just as bad at improv as rick
and morty as she tries to set up their
escape and then they pay off the bit
about the music in the egg lange
revealing that rick also has a secret
sound system hidden inside the trashcan
rockets of his ship they bring the bit
about them being the villains of the
episode back around and somehow now
summer is even worse than rick and morty
they hate her even more then too because
this is a one-off episode they try to
tie a bow on the theme of the episode
saying that it's mostly that they suck
everyone sucks then rick and morty go
back to watching interdimensional cable
referencing not trying too hard in new
episodes and finished paying off the
egg-laying bit every 30 minutes when
they wind up crapping on the floor
number one was obviously that post
credit scene tag in the bit with tricia
tried to bang jerry watch out for her
she is a freak but it actually tracks
with her character because if you go
back to season 3 there's even the
episode where she's talking about doing
super freaky stuff in bed there were a
billion references in the episode so if
you spotted any big ones that I didn't
mention in the video just write them
below in the comments it obviously my
trailer for episode 8 will post tomorrow
so everyone click here for all my Rick
and Morty episodes and click here for
that brand new Mandalorian season 2
teaser trailer for Boba Fett thank you
so much for watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!